اعلن وزير الداخليه الايرانيه احمد وحيد
في بيان له انه خلال تحقيقات الميدانيه
بشان حالات التسمم في مدارس الفتيات في
ايران تم العثور على ما وصفه بالعينات
المثيره للشبهه وقال ان هذه العينات ارسلت
الى مختبرات متخصصه وسوف يتم الاعلان عن
نتائج التحاليل عبر وزاره الصحه واضاف
وزير الداخليه انه تم تسجيل حالات تسمم 52
مدرسه على الاقل حتى اليوم وتشهد ايران
سلسله احداث تسمم في مدارس الفتيات منذ
نهايه نوفمبر تشرين الثاني الماضي يعتقد
انها ناجمه عن غاز النيتروجين كان اخرها
تسجيل حالات تسمم اليوم في ست محافظات
وافقه وكاله انباء فارس وكان الرئيس
الايراني قد قال ان حالات التسمم هي ملف
امني ياتي في اطار الحرب الاعلاميه
والنفسيه التي يشنها العدو ضد ايران
حسب تعبيره
[موسيقى]